hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
and I'm John Humphrey have been wearing
this shirt for far too long anyway we're
gonna watch the trailer for 19:17 today
you might hear some cats in the
background but before we go into this
video I'd like to say that I have a
terrible memory and I love efficiency so
big thanks to dashlane for sponsoring
today's video yes if you don't know -
Lee and they are a wonderful Identity
Management service dedicated helping you
safely store and access all of your
existing online passwords and generate
new incredibly secure ones instantly gee
how many online accounts do you have
improvised answer that's a lot or not
it's it to keep track of and it's only
gonna get worse but not when you sign up
for - Lee with their free basic service
you can store all your existing
passwords as well as payment information
manage auto fills and protect it all
with your master - Lane password which
is stored locally on your computer so
not even - lanes on servers have access
to that information and if you're
looking to take your online security a
step further - Lane premium offers these
features as well as a built in VPN for
secure browsing and dark web monitoring
to make sure your info isn't linking in
the wrong hands lord knows it has for me
and a whole lot more now - Lane's basic
service is free but when you head over
to our special link in the description
box and pin comment you can get yourself
a free 30-day trial of - Lane perineum
is available for desktop iPhone and
Android and it syncs across all your
devices so your info safe no matter
where you are and John oh the first 200
people to purchase - line perineum can
get 10% off using offer code real real
there there are so many ways to access
this service what are you waiting for
hit the link
I hope today might be a good day hope is
a dangerous tomorrow they're walking
into a trap calling off tomorrow
morning's attack
if you fail it will be a massacre
let's talk crappy that's why I love the
production design just across the German
front line
[Music]
[Music]
comment
oh that's fine Wow left standing the
[Music]
tracking shots in this yeah this is
Roger Deakins cinematography sort of
looks like
[Music]
we will lose 1600 men no brother among
them here duck
I love this shot especially the shot of
the beaters beautiful
I hope the movie plays for a long time
and then when that shot comes up 45
minutes and it still does the 1970
that's when the title card comes oh
that's always been a long way to wait
for the time if you late for the drink
when I saw the first trailer for this I
was like this looks really well shot
this looks really cool but it wasn't
until I saw the trailer and the theatres
where I was like this movie looks insane
this looks incredible the level of scope
that they do with all the framing in
here I feel like there's this illusion I
think I might have heard this actually
now I think about it that they want to
sort of create kind of like that Birdman
illusion where it looks like one shot
first so much of this well that's the
biggest surprise about this movie to me
because none of the advertising hints to
that then you go online you do some
reading and yeah this is one of those
movies that wants to be like one
extended take yeah and what the images
you're seeing here make that look like I
mean obviously it's not but such an
undertaking to even just make it appear
like that I mean it's hard to properly
advertise that yeah we cut around
different times of the day as well
either way like the incredible tracking
shots it looks so realistically I can't
tell what is CGI well it's like
everything looks practical to me that
crazy shot when that plane was coming in
the background and they were running
away for him it's like wow that yeah
looks so real how do they do that you
know
yeah I wonder I mean movies like these
where the CGI enhancements would be less
apparent or fascinating because I would
imagine that a fair amount of this could
very well have been caught in camera or
maybe done with plates so you don't need
CGI you just get the plane shot and then
you get there shot running or something
like that but yeah I mean this looks
incredibly tangible and it'll be
fascinating to see something that's also
gonna put you that much further in like
even though this is still going to be a
cinematic movie I feel like there is
something a bit more immediate and just
intense about the one-shot aspect you
know you're in real time you're living
through something and also this isn't a
period of war that we visited as much in
you know big scale cinema so tubes like
we have been more more lately yeah and
and so to be put into the shoes
in a way that is that immersive I think
will be a very fascinating experience
for you yeah well I know that when the
first trailer came out even I myself
compared some of the style of how this
is communicating the this trailer
doesn't do it as much the first trailer
seemed like they were kind of honing in
on that dunkirk fanbase yeah in terms of
tone and style this was more emotionally
gripping I'd say I don't want to like
make some comparison review because it's
just the trailer we're going off of and
it's a different movie in general I just
remember that would Dunkirk people you
know often talked about how they had
issues kind of connecting with
characters a lot of the time and it
seems like here your two main leads
you're gonna have probably no problem
looking into their emotional journey and
you're latched into their perspective as
they're trying to complete this one
harrowing mission man like the
choreography of the way you do these
action sequences and I mentioned a few
times already like I was in a short film
that was kind of this all the history
thing and there were some action
sequences that had to be done it's not
simple but when you hear choreography
you imagine you know like I don't know
fight scenes cars or whatever but but
really there's a lot of technical
staging that goes down into even getting
that last shot where the famous won't
where it's running in the 1917 logo
comes in you have to really time the
background extras the explosions the
pace that that lead actor is running at
this movie seems staged in such a
fascinating way to me that every time I
catch a trailer and the theaters I'm
like yeah I really want to see this film
and this trailer just gave me more of
that emotional pull I don't know I'll
shed a tear not but I probably might
Sandman that's one of my favorite
directors yeah well it's nice to see
something that looks like a gripping
experience to go see in a theater
granted there's going to be action I'm
sure going to be intensity but this
isn't you know a blockbuster movie
that's like oh we have to see the
Avengers fight somebody in a theater
because that's what it's made for
strange it's gonna use the time stone
that's right and Harry is gonna you know
did a kick some ass Kingsman style we
did it this can easily be a crossover
and then might as well yeah the other
thing too is I'm just happy for my man
Tommen over here getting a leading role
in a movie cuz I haven't seen him since
Game of Thrones
yeah well this looks great I think this
is one
movies I could see why there seems like
it's kind of a weird mood to put out
around Christmas but when you look at
the Oscar level or the production that
you you know it's kind of weird how we
talk about awards contender when we just
see trailers but when you see the
technical achievements just alone in
this trailer you're like well at least
the technical stuff has to get nominated
right well an amount with any war movie
I think that just alludes to like well
you know words because this is our
history and you know they're gonna take
this seriously and try and put a good
amount of dramatic credence to it yeah I
mean the Christmas thing is like going
off at Dunkirk it's like that is a hope
based war movie and I think that this is
interesting because I do see how it does
kind of align with that because the
whole point is we're preventing a
massacre we're trying to save people
it's not about a battle that was won
over other people at the same time there
is that contrast of this looks harrowing
in a different kind of way because you
know Dunkirk so rescue and this is them
going directly into a bunch of probably
war-torn or actively hot areas and the
level of mystery is sort of like what
are they gonna encounter like this looks
like it could actually be really scary
yeah that's a good word for it you know
especially when they're down in the
shadows like in these bunkers and things
and yeah I feel like this film's gonna
do a lot with perspective I'm so excited
for them this is gonna be this is gonna
be a great movie the Sam Mendes man yeah
man Inspector yeah Spectre mentor head
man Jake Gyllenhaal all right guys well
are you excited for 1917 are you
watching cats or 1917 go crazy we're
just watching back-to-back I see a loose
all right guys well thank you for being
here you can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell get
notified whenever we've got a youtube
video up I got to change my shirt
thank you to dashlane for working with
us in this video download and I wanted
to give a shout out to a man named David
Waterhouse buddy this may seem like a
weird video to give you a shout out on
but in my mind it's not what I know a
lot about soldiers who have been through
wars that they're survivors and David
every time I talk to you I always mean
it when I tell you this you are such a
strong inspirations especially to me
when I hear about all the constant
obstacles you had to overcome
you are probably out of anyone I've ever
interacted with personally you are
probably the strongest toughest survivor
ever I mean I know you've had to deal
with a lot of mental health conditions
and stuff and a lot of very unbearable
physical conditions this guy survived
being run over by a bus I believe that a
bus is still kicking man yeah I have no
idea how you are able to keep going no
matter Liam no matter what throws your
way it seems like I'll just keep coming
your way but you still keep on
persisting so David I love you buddy
I can't believe you're the one showing
us so much support when all the support
should be shown your way so I love you
dude you have a great Halloween under
your guy